(playful guitar music)
- [Narrator] Jeju is a volcanic island
off the coast of South Korea,
home to Hallasan, the highest mountain
and dormant volcano in South Korea.
The island was created entirely
from volcanic eruptions
two million years ago in the Cenozoic Era.
Check out the island’s lava tubes.
(playful music)
The island is also home
to the grandfather stones,
considered to be Gods offering
protection and fertility.
As well as it's beautiful beaches.
And a love land.
Let's leave them to it.
The island is also home to a secret.
The farm where Korean
Air grows and cultivates
food for its first-class passengers.
For years, Korean Air has operated
Je-dong Farm on the island.
The farm was originally opened
by the owners of Korean Air
in 1972 when there was a
shortage of beef in Korea.
Cattle were brought in to
help supply the country
but by the '90s, cows were everywhere,
so the farm turned its attention
to more upmarket produce.
Premium, environmentally-friendly beef.
That's one happy cow. (cow moos)
There are several barns holding
cows who will supply beef
to Korean Air's first and
business-class passengers.
There's also a very
large poultry population,
and they roam free.
(chickens clucking)
The roosters?
Well, they're just hanging
out with the ladies.
Peppers were hard to find in Korea,
so the farm started growing their own
using Jeju's clean,
volcanic artesian water.
And these lovely cherry tomatoes.
The island is also home to
the best groundwater in Korea.
Because of the layers of lava
flow and volcanic clusters,
the island has very high water absorption.
The water is withdrawn from
the ground and bottled here
at the state-of-the-art production plant.
Jeju Pure Water is clear
and clean mineral water
containing organic components
so it's great for you.
The water is also being
served on Korean Air flights.
In Seoul, the Korean Air
chefs are cooking up a treat
for the passengers.
(playful music)
Here, you can see some
of the hard work put in
by the farm and the chickens.
And how does it taste above the clouds?
Excellent, of course.
(sonar chime)